the Joe Rogan experience you know I mean
but if he does is to block people
there's ways to avoid people I block
people liberally you know it's weird
though block lists when you never even
had an interaction so I want it's like a
blacklist yeah and you go to their page
and they're blocked you just blocked
just down why no reasons people have
block lists for anyone who follows
President Trump yeah it's like if I'm a
journalist
yeah I sure as hell better be following
the [ __ ] president right know what he
says first of all he says hilarious [ __ ]
yes on the rig
look he does what's your favorite Trump
tweet Rocket Man when he was calling my
favorite one Jim John owned Rocket Man
what's the the one about the haters and
the losers yes that's a great one but he
did that before he was president yes
8000 13 it's still of my favorite route
to be very far oh yeah every time I
speak of the haters and losers I do so
with great love and affection they
cannot help the fact that they were born
[ __ ] up I would like if he said that
now as president I know that's one thing
he's really doing a great job as
president not swearing yeah that's
amazing well did you see what CNN did to
him during the campaign he said boy
that's really up so he didn't say it
they played the clip and they believed
him yes we talked about this yeah yeah
it's very dishonest yeah
they bleeped it to make it look like he
said something he didn't but he's
cursing ass blue streak in the White
House anyway we all know this but it's
funny I like it I think that part is
funny like I'm not I'm not happy with a
lot of what's going on but I'm very
happy that he's this ridiculous person I
think it's funny and I think it's very
healthy for us to have less reverence
for the president because when a
president's on a pedestal he's in a
position to send our sons and daughters
to die whereas if you look at it him as
a clown you're going to be much less
more skeptical of is this man going to
war for the right reasons is he doing
these things for the right reasons and I
think that's very and that's what the
founding fathers wanted to they didn't
want the president to be looked at as a
god yeah that's an interesting point
though I think you're correct and I
think this idea that its behavior
unfitting for a president that's what
we're thinking that a president is a
special person right that's real job and
they'll act accordingly like a gentleman
and there's human beings
it's a stupid job it's a ridiculous job
anyway and you sub Biden went after
krumping says Oh being presidential as
always yeah by definition he's always
being presidential because he's the
[ __ ] president and you're not